great set of pieces of tools here okay
but it's kind of something missing see
how you've got a product here what
happens when you don't multiply like
we've got we've got addition addition
and subtraction or more or less to say
we've got multiplication but we've seen
that mobilization just doesn't you don't
just get the part of the derivative
right so we want to develop what happens
if f of X is not a priority but if it's
a quotient we want to fill this in okay
if what I have is not you time to be
what happens if you divided by B okay so
what we're going to develop and actually
we have all the pieces to do this quite
quickly is the question rule now you
could not go back to first principles
you can almost always go back to first
principles but we have developed tools
namely the two that I'm particularly
interested in are these last two chain
rule and questions we're going to use
these to approach this thing because of
course a question right like say one of
them 4 divided by 2 I can rewrite any
question I like as a product it's just
gonna be a different pair of numbers
that I introduce right this is a
question for / - what would I have to
multiply this by in order to be the same
thing aha right so in other words
dividing by these speeds multiply by its
reciprocal okay what's my by its
reciprocal so he's only gonna do I'm
gonna rewrite if that's that's my
starting point
therefore just going on f of X is really
equal to u of X right times 1 over fears
you like with this that's pretty obvious
right yes it is but now okay I can treat
it as a question I'm sorry as a product
right it's this times this okay
now we know roughly what should happen
when we do apart we know what to do
there but this guy complicates things
right let me bring him over here for a
second let's suppose that what I have is
one over hmm let's just do one over sine
X plus one okay if this is what they
were differentiating what we're doing
this cuz you can differentiate this you
know you have enough tools of your
disposal yeah yes X plus 1 it's a power
of negative 1 right so this is better
than this because now I have in terms of
power I know what to do with powers okay
next step yeah chain rule okay so I've
got a function of a function okay so
what would I do
I would say okay minus 1 at the front
the power thing okay I reduce the power
by 1 and then I multiply by 1 what's
that last one that I put on there yeah
it's the inside isn't it sighs this guy
this guy there okay let's slightly
change the question suppose what I
started with there's not 1 over X plus 1
that's very simply what if we started
with a 2 I put a 2 in there how would
this whole thing change yeah good okay
did you uh something yeah
it doesn't make sense when I say if FG x
equals oh sorry G sorry this [ __ ] ain't
it that's what I said okay
derivative that is that okay sorry that
was my mistake
okay sorry quick go back alright so here
if I were to tie this whole thing up
what am i God it looks like I'm a minus
sign out the front Anna - and this guy's
going to go on to the denominator
do you with that 2 X plus 1 fools yep
okay now taking that knowledge over to
this guy right because this is really V
to the power of minus 1 it's the same
thing right so when I differentiate it
what's gonna happen okay let's just
let's just think about him okay firstly
I'm going to have to bring the power at
the front minus 1 this guy here yep
we'll do the rest of this okay we're
different in that this is V of X or to
the power of minus 1 so it's just like
this it's just like this situation okay
so my minus 1 has come out the front
okay I'm just gonna have V of X and then
I have to reduce its power by 1 don't
so it was most one before so now it'll
be minus 2 okay with that okay but then
I'm not finished yet right pehle came
out the front reduce the power by 1 and
then I had to do one more thing to x in
this case I multiplied by 2 why did I
multiply by 2 it's the derivative of
that inside function right now I don't
even know what that is but I can just
say its derivative should be V - right
do you hear that
okay now all of that all of that I
should stop saying it is the derivative
of that that's just that one one little
piece okay so now that I know that I'm
going to go straight into the actual
differentiation so now I'm gonna say
what's F dash okay now I have this piece
look at my normal product rule says vu -
plus UV - right second function first
function actually doesn't mark that off
because it's just a song I can flip the
order around it follow but I'm gonna
have this thing that's the second
function write times you - well that's
the derivative of the first function
which coincidentally is also called you
- then what I do I add you and then I
multiply by all of this this is the
derivative the derivative of the second
piece it's a bit of a long awful mess
isn't it but that's okay right
I've got - I'm just gonna do it word for
medical man up okay do you write with
that so in other words when I've got ya
the product all the normal protocol has
four pieces one two three four can you
see the four pieces one two
three and this autumn isn't it
okay alright now we have all the pieces
there all that's required is to tie it
up and it looks terrible but we can get
there for starters we know this is all
functions right
so I'm going to stop saying of X of X of
X of excellence that okay
did you want to raise something before I
go on you want to suggest my next line
okay all right let's tidy up and then
you can tell me the next line so what do
I got here 1 over V times G - Plus you
big bracket in there - V - then - to
mean - by the way you ever I said to you
I don't like - notation doesn't it look
just like a 1 in this context because
I've got indices flying around I'm just
gonna go with it and I'm gonna be really
obvious when I state what's gonna go
what's happening in a second you'll come
out pretty clearly oh joy new suggestion
ok so this minus here this is like this
this times this right so I'm gonna go
you - Onvia business they come up the
top - V it doesn't matter which order I
suppose but I might as well put that one
there they go ok now I want to put these
two things together because it's kind of
two terms ago it's a bit messy this guy
here right this is actually definitely
this is actually on the bottom it's a
bit that should be UV - on the squares
you agree with that now very very close
to putting these on the Commons and on
it in fact I reckon it's so easy we can
do on this line right I want B squares
in both places right so if I multiply
the denominator by me I should do the
numerator okay now you'll notice I did
something a bit funny which is I put the
video on the front instead of after
because alphabetically is not right but
it I want it to pair a lot of this okay
cuz it means less things to me to
remember okay so now I've got B you dad
- you V - that looks familiar doesn't it
all over V squared
quacked rule is a hoof the quotient rule
is a move on V squared right
though do watch out do watch out it's
not just any ordinary for there's a plus
here and there's a minus there right and
that's an easy thing to miss okay so you
can see where the - came from it came
from the fact that I'm 1 over this lets
me the minus 1 that's why I'm x minus 1
the first place okay